what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some really exciting
news about the future of the MCU but
specifically about what is about to
happen in Phase five we know that there
are a lot of people out there who really
enjoyed phase four however we also know
that there are a lot of people out there
who really didn't enjoy phase four some
say that it didn't really feel like
Marvel there wasn't a lot of
connectivity and there wasn't really
that many exciting projects and despite
whichever side that you are on or maybe
you're in the middle it looks like
Marvel Studios is about to take it up a
notch and they do say that that was
indeed a building phase which we all
knew plus not to mention we never had
the inclusion of any Disney plus series
before so this was brand new territory
and from what it sounds like Bob chapek
really put an emphasis on Disney plus so
he was kind of demanding as far as what
he wanted and how much he wanted but
with Bob Iger back it seems that we are
going to be focusing more on creativity
and quality more moving ahead with all
things Disney and of course that
includes Marvel and recently a
screenwriter from Marvel Studios has
told us that things are about to get
very different in the MCU and basically
be taken up to a very higher level plus
not to mention we've had some reports
over the past couple of months that
state that Kevin feige wasn't exactly
pleased with phase 4 either but now he
has recently commented on superhero
fatigue as in people getting tired of
superhero movies so of course we'll have
to talk about that today as well but
first let's talk about how Phase 5 is
about to really pick things up for the
MCU by talking about what writer Jeff
lovnes had to say Jeff loveness is a
screenwriter from Marvel Studios and he
recently wrote Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania now this is a huge film keep
in mind this isn't just the next Ant-Man
film this is the official and true
introduction of the big bad of the
entire Multiverse Saga King and it seems
like it's been confirmed that we are
going to kind of get Kang's background
and kind of his origin story in in this
film so it's very very big plus if you
caught my video yesterday you know that
Paul Rudd and the director of the film
Peyton Reed both confirmed in an
interview that we are going to be seeing
some surprising faces in cameos in the
movie so this is a huge movie and it's
going to start off a new exciting phase
and here's what he recently had to say
about Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
King and phase 4 now going into phase
five and how it's going to be different
in an interview with Games Radar here's
what he had to say king is a top tier
A-list Avengers villain what do you do
when you feel you're not enough against
that how do you step up to face the
challenge of this generation who is
Thanos on an exponential level he's
almost this infinite Thanos I think
we're setting things up for a pretty
Dynamic story as I'm building to
Avengers I want it to feel like a
generational struggle so here we're
talking about building up Phase 5 and
phase six and what phase four was he
continued used to say phase 4 felt like
the birth of new characters you're
giving everyone a little bit of a breath
you're broadening out the universe you
have fun Disney plush shows that are
elevating characters and now I think
it's time to put the pedal to the gas
again and really take all these new
characters that we like and throw them
into the fire so before we really dive
into what he just said and talk about
what Kevin feige had to say about
superhero fatigue let's talk about how
nice it is that Marvel Studios
essentially does take feedback from the
fans no we don't really control anything
at least not to a major extent however
Marvel Studios does hear this feedback
and a lot of times they kind of make
minor changes to some things because
they think that it'll be received better
from the fans and this is something that
I actually admire about the studio and
in this case I think there's been a lot
that's been said about phase four I
think the studio has heard it and I
think they're making sure that Phase 5
is going to be on a different tone and
on a different level and like they said
it was a building phase before
introducing new characters and kind of
giving us a little bit of a breather but
as Jeff lovnes says that's over they're
about to be thrown into the fire phase
five is going to be different and I
think the biggest reason that Phase 5 is
going to be different is what Jeff
loveness had to say about Kang and how
he's basically an infinite Thanos but
here's how he's truly going to be
different this is a big difference
between him and Thanos as how they were
introduced into the MCU we're going to
see Kang in many different projects
before the Kang Dynasty and Avenger
Secret Wars we are actually going to
truly get to know who King the Conqueror
is so we are going to know him on a more
personal level Thanos wasn't really in
any other films he had small cameos or
post-credit scenes but really his main
introduction and his story came in just
two films the final two films of that
Saga this is kind of the opposite we're
experiencing Kang from the very
beginning of phase four when we met he
who remains and he explain basically who
him and his variants are so we're going
to get to know him on a very personal
level in fact Jeff loveness even tells
us a little bit about King he says
King's also a very lonely character
we're going to be seeing a lot of him in
a lot of different ways going forward
but I really wanted to introduce the
humanity and even the vulnerability of
this character before he gets to such
apocalyptic Avengers scale Heights so
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania is
going to be an Avengers level movie and
the next time we see Kang in another
film or maybe even a Disney plus project
like Loki season 2 it's going to be
pretty apocalyptic and Avengers level as
well so Phase 5 and phase six the
projects inside of them are going to be
on a much more elevated level very
different from phase 4 which is super
exciting and guess what Marvel is not
stopping a lot of people have asked if
the Marvel Cinematic Universe will ever
come to an end or maybe they'll reset
well according to Kevin feige no Kevin
feige was recently on the movie business
podcast where he was asked about
superhero fatigue and how long Marvel
Studios will last and how long they will
essentially make superhero movies for
and here's what he had to say I've been
at Marvel Studios for over 22 years and
most of us here at Marvel Studios have
been around a decade or longer together
from probably my second year at Marvel
people were asking well how long is this
going to last is this fad of comic book
movies going to end and he says I didn't
really understand the question because
to me it was akin to sane after Gone
With the Wind well how many more movies
can be made off of novels do you think
the audience will sour on movies being
adapted from books you would never ask
that because there's an inherent
understanding amongst most people that a
book can be anything a novel can have
any type of story whatsoever so it all
depends on what story you're translating
non-comic readers don't understand that
it's the same thing in comics and then
here is where he addresses stories
moving forward in the MCU about
superheroes of course he says there's 80
years of the most interesting emotional
groundbreaking stories that have been
told in the Marvel Comics and it's our
great privilege to be able to take what
we have and adapt them another way to do
that is adapting them into different
genres and what types of movies we want
to make I found that if we tell the
story right and we adapt them in a way
that the audience is still knock on wood
so far is following us along 22 plus
years later we can make any types of
movies that share two things the Marvel
Studios logo above the title and a seed
of an idea from our publishing history
so for those of you who have been asking
that question will Marvel Studios ever
stop making superhero movies the answer
is no at least not on Kevin feige's
watch there's a lot of stories they can
tell there's so many characters they can
tell the stories about and they've
already begun to explore the different
genres out there like werewolf by night
was horror doctor strange and the
Multiverse of Madness was horror so
they're branching out into different
genres resident sounds like Marvel
Studios has a lot of big plans in store
for us for Phase 5 and Phase 6 and then
beyond because after that we're going to
start getting the X-Men and the
Fantastic Four that's going to be the
focus in Phase 7 and Beyond so Marvel
Studios right now is looking super
bright and I think fans are about to
really love what is about to come in
Phase five and phase six but hey let me
know your thoughts about this in the
comments down below please don't forget
to like the video and subscribe to stay
up to date on the latest MCU news and
for live updates you can follow us on
Instagram and Twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching wolf wolf